[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 más
de 5000 mujeres fueron reportadas como
desaparecidas en perú y 138 perecieron
víctimas de feminicidio a lo largo del
año 2020 las autoridades alertan que en
promedio cada dos horas una mujer
desaparece en la nación andina esta es
la otra pandemia que afecta al país un
fenómeno que tristemente se repite a lo
ancho del planeta en el marco de
violencias machistas que se agudizaron y
se invisibilizaron aún más por la crisis
sanitaria de kobe 19
vamos a conocer una de las historias de
desaparición en perú un ejemplo del
sufrimiento de miles de familias que no
saben dónde están las mujeres que aman o
si siguen con vida nuestro corresponsal
en lima francisco zacarías nos reporta
esta problemática
la familia alvarado lópez sufre desde
hace más de un año la mayor de sus
angustias
[Música]
karime alvarado de 39 años salió a
comprar dulces para una fiesta infantil
y nunca más volvió no aquí espero que al
menos
que haya sido secuestrado captada por
por
por trata de personas y le hacían por
destruyendo contra su voluntad fuera de
lima en lo que yo besé pienses llamarnos
la policía la puede encontrar la puede
ubicar y la puede traer de nuevo a la
calle así como karina alvarado 5.550
mujeres niñas y adolescentes fueron
reportadas como desaparecidas en perú la
defensoría del pueblo alerta que mil 686
mujeres adultas y 3.835 niñas y
adolescentes desaparecieron en los
últimos 12 meses el organismo exige al
estado peruano articular acciones para
protegerlas todavía está pendiente para
tener una cifra real de lo que ocurre
que desde la policía nacional del perú
se pueda ir haciendo un registro
estadístico de cuántas mujeres han
aparecido cuántas con vida cuántas están
a buen recaudo con su familia y cuántas
todavía continúan en la situación de
desaparición y cuántas como las que
nosotros tenemos la contabilidad por
feminicidio aparecieron lamentablemente
ya como cada
cada día desaparecen 15 mujeres según
cifras oficiales diversos sectores del
país critican al gobierno peruano por su
deficiencia en entender esta
problemática las autoridades aseguran
que están fortaleciendo un sistema
especializado para prevenir y sancionar
la violencia contra las mujeres y
brindar una atención oportuna a ellas y
sus familias nosotros tenemos un trabajo
conjunto con la policía
hemos armado la subcomisión de trabajo
porque lo que queremos hacer es que
inter opere nuestra nuestra data es
decir las siglas los nombres de las
personas que han desaparecido para
poderlas cruzar con la información de
mujeres que han denunciado por
feminicidio por violencia
por ejemplo para saber si han sido
objeto de algún tipo de protección desde
el ministerio y poderlas ubicar el
hermano de karina alvarado no sé es en
su búsqueda tiene la esperanza que ella
aparezca en cualquier momento porque
como él afirma la esperanza es lo último
que se pierde
no hay respuestas para las familias de
las personas desaparecidas esta es una
angustia interminable y una
imposibilidad de actuar o incluso vivir
un duelo y la vida simplemente se
detiene para el que no sabe el paradero
de un ser querido vamos a conversar de
esto con patricia sarmiento ella es
comisionada adjunta de los derechos de
la mujer en la defensoría del pueblo del
perú patricia bienvenida a ella soy y
quiero preguntarle que nos dicen estas
denuncias cómo es que cinco mil mujeres
desaparecen sin dejar rastro y qué se
está haciendo desde la defensoría del
pueblo para hallarlas
sí buenos días ante todo muchas gracias
por la invitación es así como comentaban
en la noche de prensa para nosotros
resulta preocupante el hecho de que en
el año 2020 haya habido una cantidad tan
fuerte de mujeres desaparecidas mujeres
niñas y adolescentes tomando en cuenta
que en nuestro país al igual que otros
países la región nos vamos a encontrar
en un periodo de cuarentena y después de
que digamos por el estado de emergencia
sanitario las del tema de la limitación
en el tránsito de las personas debería
haber ayudado a que las mujeres no
desaparecieran porque aparentemente
había menos personas en la calle pero
eso no no se ha dado de esta manera no
las mujeres siguen desapareciendo y lo
más grave es que no sabemos qué pasa con
ellas después no sabemos si vuelven a
aparecer si no vuelven a aparecer y en
qué situación es que vuelven a aparecer
en el único caso que tenemos siempre
información es en el caso de los
feminicidios que también la reporta la
defensoría del pueblo donde si nos da
cuenta que al menos aporta
las mujeres que fueron víctimas de
feminicidio en el año 2020 fueron
reportadas como desaparecido hasta antes
de que se hallaran sus cuerpos pero
entonces existe un fallo en el sistema
de justicia y en la fiscalía para hacer
el seguimiento a todos estos casos y
estas denuncias y además después mire la
mayoría de las desaparecidas son niñas
son mujeres que están indefensas que
dependen completamente de los mayores de
edad y esto confirma si hay más
desapariciones en pandemia pues lo que
tanto hemos dicho que la casa es el
lugar más peligroso para las mujeres
exacto nosotros también venimos diciendo
es que lamentablemente y eso se compra
desde hace mucho tiempo
el tema de la violencia contra la mujer
la violencia el mayor espacio de riesgo
para ellas no es el espacio público
contrariamente a lo que siempre se ha
creído que las mujeres no deberían salir
solas a la calle porque hay mucho riesgo
sino que la mayoría de los agresores
tanto de feminicidios como en cualquier
otro tipo de manifestación de la
violencia son personas cercanas a su
entorno entonces si el tema de una
cuarentena y de las limitaciones que ha
habido en los últimos meses debido a la
emergencia sanitaria si ha contribuido a
que la situación de las mujeres en
nuestro país o las que ya tenían una
situación de violencia alrededor se haya
agudizado no más aún si a ellos les
sumamos que todos los servicios del
estado incluido a la policía incluido en
los servicios de salud públicos
el tema de tratamiento de los pacientes
de kobe y de esta manera un poco con los
guía poco recursos que se contaba antes
para poder trabajar el tema de violencia
y resguardar que se cumplan con la media
de protección a favor de las mujeres y
más aún el tema de la búsqueda de
mujeres desaparecidas ese poco el
recurso humano se ha visto diezmado aún
más por el tema de la prioridad de la
pandera bueno pero ya sabemos que estos
problemas existían desde antes de que
llegara la pandemia eso también está
clarísimo simplemente se hicieron más
visibles ahora que cada persona está en
su casa y que disminuye la movilidad de
las calles y por eso yo quisiera invitar
la acc y muy conscientemente para que me
ayude haciendo una autocrítica y me
cuente qué es lo que está fallando desde
su punto de vista en los sistemas de
justicia y de atención de atención a las
víctimas
sí bueno en realidad lo que nosotros
hemos recomendado en primer lugar es el
ministerio de las justas y poblaciones
vulnerables que nuestro país es que el
ente rector que regule el tema de
violencia contra las mujeres que
reconozca la violencia la desaparición
de mujeres como una manifestación de
violencia porque nosotros tenemos
políticas públicas y normas que
establecen cuáles son las maneras que
reconocen diversas manifestaciones de
violencia contra la mujer pero la
desaparición de mujeres no está entre
dije no y la verdad y lo cierto es que
tanto organismos internacionales como la
realidad si nos demuestran que la
desaparición de mujeres está
estrechamente ligado al tema de
violencia ese es un primer punto el
segundo punto es que venimos trabajando
con la policía nacional para que se
mejore el registro de las mujeres
desaparecidas no sólo para saber en qué
momento desaparecen sino también para
saber qué es lo que pasa después de su
desaparición cuánto tiempo tarda
encontrarlas en qué situación son
ubicadas por no son ubicadas cuánto
tiempo
[Música]
permanecer una mujer desaparecida para
tener un diagnóstico más claro de qué es
lo que pasa detrás de estas
desapariciones mientras no sepamos
cuántos aparecieron que fue de ellas y
sólo sabemos que desaparecieron sin
renunciar en esta historia no vamos a
saber poder identificar cuáles son los
factores que llevan a que estas mujeres
aparezcan y poder diseñar implementar
políticas públicas de prevención para
evitar este tipo
claro patricia y ahí entonces le tengo
que preguntar cuando lo van a saber
porque todas estas cifras de las que
usted me ha hablado y que hemos
comentado en este reporte son las cifras
del 2020 ya empezó el 2021 ya estamos
casi en febrero entonces yo le
preguntaría ya están ustedes en un
trabajo de empezar a reconocer esos
baches que tienen en las historias de
estas mujeres que no aparecen
como nosotros venimos a que el año
pasado de que advertimos este tema de la
falta de un seguimiento en el registro
venimos sosteniendo reuniones con el
ministerio del interior para poder
mejorar su sistema de registros y saber
qué pasa con estas mujeres pero ello
implica también que sea un trabajo
coordinado con el ministerio público la
fiscalía y el poder judicial que son
finalmente donde está esta ruta crítica
que pasa en las mujeres de evidencia no
entonces que se viene trabajando bien
con estos sectores la defensoría viene
trabajando para fortalecer el trabajo
interinstitucional en esta área
con la mirada de que esto este registro
pueda subsanar estas faltas en el menor
tiempo posible y a partir de ello
nosotros poder realizar un diagnóstico
más acertado de lo que viene pasando con
las mujeres desaparecidas y proponer
soluciones y recomendaciones para
políticas públicas más efectivas
bueno pues le agradezco mucho por la
información que nos brinda y por todo
este trabajo que esperamos de frutos en
los siguientes meses nosotros desde aquí
vamos a estar haciendo todo el
seguimiento de este tema
patricia muchas gracias a usted y que
tenga feliz día
muchas gracias a ustedes igualmente en
nuestros televidentes que continúen con
nosotros en france24 y nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]